my name is Alec pillar I was a strong
proponent of the campus carry bill on
the University of Texas at Austin campus
I plan to go get my concealed carry
license the first time I'm able to I
will be turning a page but we will nice
couple weeks here and I do plan to carry
at some point in the future
[Music]
[Applause]
I started handling firearms when I was
about four or five years old my father
went out and bought a BB gun it wasn't
until I was about 12 or 13 where I
actually started shooting live rounds at
a shooting range my primary reason for
one to conceal carry a weapon on campus
is I believe as a last line of defense
it is up to me to protect myself and if
there is a law that legally allows me to
do that and I'm gonna take advantage of
it
[Music]
I just really vehement ly do not want
guns in my classroom I feel as though my
freedom of expression has been stifled
because of that fear that I feel that
there are loaded guns in my classmates
backpacks and that's something that I
shouldn't have to worry about according
to Texas Penal Code forty three point
twenty two dildos are a Class C
misdemeanor so if you openly carry a sex
toy you get about a five hundred dollar
fine but having a loaded handgun in a
backpack if we are twenty-one enough and
have had four hours of training that's
perfectly legal and so what we wanted to
do was fight absurdity with absurdity
there's never been evidence in any mass
shooting that's shown up in the research
that a concealed carrier with four hours
of training that's the minimum required
in Texas has been able to intervene in
an active shooter situation anywhere I
don't want to put my faith or the
well-being of the students in my
classroom in the hands of some overly
confident minimally trained person
carrying a lethal weapon
[Music]
do I feel fearful for my own safety I do
think about moving around the campus
differently there was a bullet casing
with a message left on the bulletin
board right outside of my door that said
got triggered and it was some jerk you
know trying to intimidate us but that
made me aware of the changed climate on
campus
[Music]
you do look at more of all these math
students are having their in gun-free
zones
someone that's going in with a gun and
the intent to kill someone is not
looking to get into a gunfight they're
looking to kill as many people as
possible they're not looking for you to
shoot back and I believe it is in your
best interest to carry a gun if you can
legally I think some of my concerns are
for students of color in particular I
had a colleague say to me but there's
always been guns on campus and sorority
girls always have guns and I just
thought about that it's like well
couldn't be just a large black man
crossing the street between the
intersection like we all do looking
around campus you know at night and
getting too close to someone who might
be a little jumpy and that you know
well-intended sorority girl might chew
you know one of her fellow students who
looks large and scary at night
you